okay now we're going to go to five
headlines
[Music]
five headlines sponsored by benham
brothers learn how to own a business
without it owning you get a 15
discount on the benton brothers new
course expert ownership at
benhambrothers.com
walsh so representative yoho of florida
a few days ago got into a bit of a
heated exchange with representative
alexandria casa cortez
outside of the capitol building in
washington
and in this exchange yoho was mad at
cortez for
specifically for some of the stuff she's
been saying about the rioting and chaos
and the violence
and how she tried to claim that all this
is happening because people just want
bread for their families
and um he said riojo said to cortez
you're out of your freaking mind
um which well you can see why he would
think that and then she called him rude
and
as they left parted ways yoho said of
cortez
but i don't think to her but said it
sort of under his breath as he walked
away
effing b word only he didn't say
ethic b where he said the words
themselves that was overheard by a
reporter so you may not believe it but
we should note that yoho was asked about
it and his response was no comment
and then the guy he was walking with
another lawmaker
was asked what happened and here's here
was his response he said
i was actually thinking as i was walking
down the stairs i was thinking about
some issues i've got in my district that
need to get done
i don't know what their topic was
there's always a topic isn't there
so that's a good that's a good friend
folks that's uh he ain't snitching um
i just love that his excuse is that he
didn't hear the argument because he was
just so
immersed in thinking about his district
and wanting to help the the folks back
home
um you know totally believable of course
great stuff there
now this is all a setup to tell you
about
the only part of this that concerns
anyone really
cortez decided to spend time on the
floor of the house
pandemic going on chaos in the street
country
in turmoil she decides to waste taxpayer
payers time
on the house floor complaining about the
mean words that someone said to her uh
here she is i walked back out
and there were reporters in the front of
the capitol
and in front of reporters representative
yoho called me
and i quote
these are the words that representative
yoho
levied against a congresswoman
the congresswoman that not only
represents new york's 14th congressional
district
but every congresswoman and every woman
in this country
because all of us have had to deal with
this
in some form some way some shape
at some point in our lives this issue
is not about one incident it is
cultural it is a culture of lack of
impunity
of accepting of violence and violent
language
against women an entire structure of
power
that supports that and that went on for
almost 10 minutes
get over it he said a bad word this
isn't 9 11 okay it's not a national
tragedy we don't need your 10-minute
speech about someone saying something
mean to you
this doesn't concern anyone but the two
people involved
no one else cares why should anyone else
care what possible relevance is it
you guys got into an argument he called
you a bad word okay hey you know
sorry i would what do you want
and no yoho was not using abusive
language towards women you know she's
trying to turn this into an attack on
all
it's not an attack on all women he
wasn't abusing he wasn't using abusive
language towards
towards women he was using abusive
language towards one particular woman it
was an attack
on one it was a personal attack on one
particular individual
it was not an attack on all women
everywhere a personal attack
and that's relevant because personal
attack means
deal with it on your own time deal with
it on your personal time go talk to him
and tell him that he hurts your feelings
that's fine it's it's not something that
everyone needs to hear about
i mean this this whole thing that we get
especially from liberal women
anytime they're insulted or attacked
this is an assault on all women
everywhere
no it's not he just doesn't like you i'm
not defending what he said
not saying it was the right thing to say
but this concerns you
and him you're not a representative for
all women everywhere
in fact i'm guessing that well over half
the women in the country
or at least half uh would would would
say that
you don't quite represent them or their
values i i i feel pretty safe
saying that there are millions of women
in this country who do not consider
alexandria queso cortez to be a
representative of them
and then and then of course you know she
she during this soliloquy she uh
proceeds to act as though you know
this this never happens to men you know
this this happens to women far too often
we get
yeah okay you know men get insulted too
all the time okay men get called
sexually degrading names also um
and uh you know it's even actually more
acceptable in society to do that so
it really happens to everybody not a
huge deal
deal with it on your own time um
number two president trump at a press
conference yesterday said something that
people of course are upset about as
usual but
tell me what's wrong with this take a
listen if schools do not
reopen the funding should go to parents
to send their
child to public private charter
religious or
home school of their choice the key word
being
choice yeah you want to talk about
defunding things well if it's
if there is a certain service that the
government refused
refuses to render then we shouldn't be
funding that service money shouldn't be
going
i shouldn't be paying for a service that
the government will not provide
now as a homeschool parent and a
taxpayer i'm already paying for
educational services that i don't use
which is bad enough as it is but
if it's a service that no one can use
because the government refuses to fully
provide it
then it shouldn't be funded we shouldn't
have to pay for it i think that's pretty
simple
number three a horrible case in florida
three friends out on a fishing trip were
murdered
um by a man named tony wiggins tony t.j
wiggins wiggins had two accomplices but
it seems that he's the one who
led this thing and pulled the trigger
now this is pretty chilling um there's
cctv footage not of the murder
but of what happened 10 minutes before
okay
damien tillman one of the victims along
with two of his friends were killed on a
fishing trip
um ran into a convenience store on the
way to uh you know to to their fishing
spot
pick up a few things and there uh
tillman ran into wiggins and they had an
exchange and you would think that
okay this is going to be an exchange of
them having an argument or some kind of
uh fight or something and then that led
to violence
but no that's actually not what happened
watch this you know you can't hear what
they're saying but you can see the
exchange there
so you see this is appears to be
and i believe the store clerk confirmed
just a friendly conversation they're
having
um they had a friendly exchange no
argument completely polite
and normal or so it seemed but as
tillman left
wiggins and his brother and uh his
girlfriend
followed them in their truck tracked
them to a spot in the woods where they
were going
and then murdered all three of them
apparently there was some story wiggins
had about how one of the friends had
stolen a car engine or
something like that um that was the
pretense for the murder
i don't know if there's any evidence
that any theft occurred not that it
matters at all
this was cold-blooded execution for no
real reason
now here's the point to take home from
this aside from how evil and tragic it
is
wiggins had 230 felonies
no that's not i'm not misreading that
230
felonies on his record 15 convictions
had already been to state prison twice
and many of his convictions were for
violent crimes
these weren't all drug crimes okay these
were assaulting police officers
assaulting the elderly
among others and yet here is this
scumbag this evil
satanic filth out again on bond i
believe
he murders three people so
you know i say again we talk about
criminal justice reform oh we need
criminal justice reform
we do need criminal justice reform but
that is reform that keeps dangerous
criminals in prison
that's the real problem we have with our
justice system it's not that a bunch of
innocent people are going to jail
now that does happen but it's not
happening on a large scale i'll tell you
what is happening on a large scale
dangerous parasites
are sent to prison because they commit
you know violent crime and then are let
go
and then they commit another crime let
go again commit another crime
they just keep they they keep filtering
their back into the community
until eventually they do something so
horrible that now the system has no
choice but to keep them behind bars
you shouldn't get 15 chances okay
number four america magazine which is a
jesuit publication has this article
today
uh an article which proves my point that
all jesuits should be
excommunicated um the article is
uh the article's titled the crucifixion
of george floyd
yes crucifixion of george floyd let me
give you a little sampling a little
morsel of this it says the parallels
between particulars are of
the crucifixion most familiar to us as a
report of the new testament and that of
george floyd are haunting
it no it's not haunting because there
are no parallels there are
zero parallels but let's see the
argument they make here
it should be stressed at the outset that
in 33 a.d crucifixion was not reserved
for those who claim to be the son of god
or the king of the jews
or who posed other threats to civil
authority it was
the great show no mercy lesson to
thieves murderers and other criminals
the authorities wanted to punish
in the most aggravating way possible
jesus was laid on the ground to be
nailed to the cross
george floyd was laid down on the ground
and pinned by derek chovin's knee on his
neck
as time passed jesus suffered from
thirst george floyd asked for water
both jesus and george floyd were
repeatedly mocked by their killers
jesus cried out to his father and george
floyd
called for his mother shortly before he
lost consciousness he said
i'm through i'm through in other words
it is finished the story of christ's
crucifixion was not written down for
almost half a century in our time to a
great credit
the crucifixion of george floyd was
instantaneously touched and galvanized
the nation and beyond
daddy changed the world his six-year-old
daughter said at the funeral service for
george floyd in houston texas sam cook's
great civil rights anthem
a change is going to come rang out
seeing it through
all the way whatever it takes now falls
to us
the living i mean this is
i mean what else can be said about this
kind of thing that i haven't already
said
um literal
literal canonization and more of george
floyd
and by the way i know i have to i
shouldn't have to tell this is a
you know supposed to be a christian
magazine but these are jesuits so i do
have to
say that uh george floyd when he said
i'm through i'm through yeah he meant
i'm gonna die when when jesus said
it is finished he meant his
saving act was finished so this had a
much deeper meaning than just
i'm going to die and
many other differences as well i
that's just one one difference between
the crucifixion
of jesus christ our lord and savior and
the death of
george floyd which i i think has been
well established by now was
is a sad thing and unjust
um and fortunately it's
it's in the courts now it's in it's in
the hands of the court as it should be
all of that is true it's also true
that george floyd was uh not a good man
to put it mildly this was a man who um
forced his way into a woman's home
robbed her
at gunpoint in her home in front of her
child
an unspeakably violent
evil act george floyd committed among
other crimes
does that mean that he deserved to die
no okay
but it does mean that we should be very
reluctant to canonize him or turn him
into
jesus christ or you know to to
memorialize him in a way
that celebrates the man he was because
there's not a lot to celebrate there
so it requires a certain restraint that
i think a lot of people these days are
not
capable of um if you're capable of just
saying
he didn't deserve to die this was a
terrible thing
and you want to leave it at that fine
agreed
you start going into this nonsense
okay now we have an issue and now it
becomes necessary to bring up that oh by
the way this was a man who
committed a horrible act against a woman
um
again among other crimes number five
finally a swarm of bees
descended onto a beach in new jersey
this is b news you know i have to
have to hit it the the the the bees
gathered on the back of a chair about a
beach towel
so there's the picture of it and here's
a local news report about this incident
watch
new video showing a different kind of
beach overcrowding in cape may
that big brown blob on the back of the
beach chair
is a swarm of bees the stinging insects
stormed the sand yesterday they were
swarming around until they landed on a
towel a beekeeper wrapped them
in a towel placed them in a box and word
is around there that the bees took
flight when somebody knocked the queen
out of her nearby nest so you mess with
the queen
you mess with them that's right and you
see there that's why
when we talk about first responders we
should be talking about beekeepers too
i've always said this my community we
are also first responders we are the
first people who are called in any be
related emergency
and we save many lives every year
thousands of lives
mostly bee lives but but still lives or
lives all right
we're all equal i believe that
and can i just say also there's there's
some misinformation in that report um
they didn't swarm because someone
knocked the queen out of a nest all
right
bees swarm when the original hive is
overcrowded so the queen will take about
you know a third or so of
the workers they go off to start a new
hive they were looking for a new home
that's that's why they were there okay
they had every right to be there
just like anybody else on the beach
uh the bees at the old hive will appoint
a new queen and actually
they well they don't they they select a
few larvae um
and they convert them into into queens
by feeding them royal jelly which is the
substance they secrete from their
from their heads and uh and then
whichever queen emerges
will then go and murder the other baby
queens
seizing power and beginning her reign of
terror and that's the whole reason i
like bees really because i can relate so
much
um to to that and to their experiences
in general in many ways so a little bit
of b news that's good
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt walsh show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content